hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play lusus aleosis
I'm not sure but this has been on my
list to play for a long time I just
haven't gotten a chance to get around to
it until now and also um this was really
I think two months ago I'm not sure but
there was a recent update that updated
it to version 1.2 and in the changelog
they said that they added new monsters
and all sorts of stuff like that so I
haven't played this before I haven't
seen anything about it so this should be
pretty interesting for me let's go I'm
sure I'm going to do just fine from what
I've heard people sit out of 1992 when I
received the letter from my mother
asking me to visit her at our home town
in the letter she told me that she
wanted to see me and also mentioned that
she wanted to talk to me about my father
that made me curious because my father
had died before I was born and mother
rarely talked about her I decided to
travel at night to avoid traffic after
three hours of driving I reached the
country road and I was getting pretty
tired it was dark outside and I still
had a long way to go
okay so as you can see this is really
well made in the game and yes it is in
indie game links in the description
below as always if you want to play for
yourself but I can tell that a lot of
work has been put into this game I mean
the voice acting was good on the the
graphics are pretty impressive for
everything I mean it's incredibly
detailed I think it's made on the Unreal
Engine as opposed to a lot of games that
are made on the oh I'm sorry I should be
reading this my car is wrecked I need to
continue on foot to help as many games
are made on the Unity engine this one is
actually made on the Unreal Engine so
I'm not sure what the difference is
between the two of them but we seem to
have our giant rock oh hello it's like
amnesia you can move things with your
hand or you can't move things with your
hand
oh you can't move things with your hand
okay whoa I just shot that rock right
through that rock I'm so strong okay so
there's a path here it seems to be a
path here maybe I could lease you a
village
I better take my things from my trunk
okay before I head out what happens if I
go down the road where am I going where
could I possibly be going that Oh need
to do that no dead bodies back here okay
hey no I'm gonna I want to explore a bit
because I want to make sure that I don't
overlook anything because this is a type
of adventure game I know that there's
gonna be a tote it's too far to go on
foot I need to find another way to Oh
invisible whoa ah okay all right um
there's probably invisible walls to keep
me from being an idiot so I guess I'll
go to the village is this the village
that I wanted to go in the first place
and why am I going on foot this doesn't
seem like a smart decision why did I
Drive at night which hour of traffic
would there be in the middle of the
night on a dirt road even in the day on
a dirt road how much traffic could there
possibly be this doesn't make any sense
okay enough questioning it obviously
since I'm in the woods and the graphics
were really nice I really like this a
lot of work has been put into this and I
really appreciate that but it kind of
reminds me what's over here
of slender Oh
bench just because you're in the woods
and stuff like that but I believe most
of the Slender games were made on the
unity engine hello I want some water
please no thank you
okay so yeah just look there's like an
incredible amount of detail just in the
environment everywhere I mean that this
is really what makes a game atmospheric
is the amount of detail that's put into
things that seem inconsequential to the
game but it's actually all well here's a
mistake oh my goodness oh my god well
everything's been broken that tree root
ruined everything for me oh here we go
okay so we're walking into this
mysterious village shut up where I'm
sure that everything is gonna be just
fine it's an old village maybe I can ask
for help here okay ding-dong anybody
home ding-dong it's locked
let me guess everything's locked why
wouldn't everything be locked need my
flashlight kind of dark in here ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding nope okay ding
ding ding ding ding okay pretty much
everything is gonna be locked in the
village from now on ding ding ding hi
honey get over to there hi let me over
there okay it's probably locked anyway
ding ding ding ah my fossae it's locked
well thinks oh of course it wouldn't be
a haunted village without giant pools of
blood everywhere what is this hi hi I've
been through enough 4 games to not trust
that no thank you
ding dong anybody anybody it Oh anybody
duh oh thank god guard me they locked to
be in please help me get out ok what
happened
where's the key they took the key with
them as they were leaving I heard one of
them say to the other in vino veritas I
hope that makes sense to you ok and
walked you in and why just hurry and
I'll explain everything to you later
they could come back any moment now in
vino veritas of course means my
flashlight batteries are dead oh it
means the truth in wine how does this
guy know Latin I'm gonna assume then
this guy's a psychotic crazy bastard
right from the get-go cuz that's pretty
much a safe bet all the time I was gonna
say in life Veritas in life very toss
hmm yes true
very very good words to live by
ding-dong nobody's home no maybes hey if
we're gonna be home this this is this
wine no it's water whole town's full of
drunks they just got wine pouring
straight out of via the phone there for
everyone to drink okay so here's a good
place to throw myself off the ledge if I
could actually go I want to go over
there
let me over hmm jump there nope okay so
that's another invisible wall they don't
want me doing anything stupid hang on
okay I already checked out so there's
got to be some sort of a wine cellar
ding-dong it's unlocked that doesn't
seem like very hard to unlock since
considering it's just a little thing I
think the other gate was like that too
but this guy's so wimpy and stupid that
he can't quite do it hello
ooh physics physics wooden things
actually fall at a normal rate in case
you didn't know in amnesia when things
fall they fall in sort of like slow
motion but that actually falls pretty
nice dang dong oh oh it opened ooh ooh
it's dark flashlight what it doesn't
work it's out of gas is that it oh it's
a generator okay so I need to get gas
for the generator oh that's not a
foreign concept but let's see what's
down here I can't really see anything
and I don't have my flashlight I just
see like outlines of things and then
nothing else so sorry if you guys can't
see anything but I can't see anything
either to some sort of boxes and I think
there's a barrel I'm not sure okay
anyway getting out of there cuz I know
if I stick around in the place where I'm
not supposed to be before I get gas dang
dong it's gonna eat me up is this
important
- the wheel-to-wheel huh okay seems like
nothing alright moving forward ding-dong
nope okay why these days one of these
doors is gonna be unlocked nope
everything is locked
why is everything locked and why is
everything locked from the outside see
there locks on the outside of these
doors I mean it's not like I couldn't
bust through them but I think I don't
want to be rude to the people who live
here okay so anyway I'm looking hello
hello huh it's a trap push it push it
finish it
oh I can see there's like rolling logs
set up for a trap for me probably Sam
with the rock I mean it's obviously that
someone threw that rock at me to try to
stop my car for some strange reason my
own mother is betraying me or or I'm a
psycho crazy person and I am making up
I'm not even in a town right now I'm
just I'm sort of just wandering around
in the woods alone hey wait a minute
this looked familiar ah a trap put your
trap
it's an axe and my axe oh I know as a
son of a [ __ ] get out of here uh-oh
that didn't do anything I probably I
probably messed with the trap when I
moved those logs around whoops my bad
really dark in these woods I can't see
anything
why is it always so dark why can't I
have my flashlight why can't I be in
happy fun times village why can't I go
to a nice village during the day with
with lights and summer and joy and such
what's have to be depressing what's over
here anything ah come on
I'm so wimpy I can't jump over that okay
so I'm in the river I'm guessing that
there's nothing in the river there had
to be some reason to come down here
because I'm looking for a key but I'm
sure pretty sure the key is in that wine
cellar um I need to get gas so we're am
I gonna get gas I don't know maybe this
whole river is just a giant oil spill
and I need to find something in the
water
I don't have anything I have an axe I'm
going to attack the water I attacked the
darkness yeah well I can just hold the
axe in front of me like this
this is gonna be very valuable ah going
into complete darkness with the axe in
front of me it works for me an ex mortis
I'm sure it can work for me in other
places I am missing something or not I I
feel I feel the stupid coming upon me
pretty strongly so if you guys are like
see something that remember I haven't
played this game before so I have no
idea what I'm doing so I'm just kind of
wandering loss through the woods oh
maybe I was supposed to follow the trail
down well I might have been smart I
might have been smart I still don't see
anything and I literally can't see
anything on the other side of that River
wait was that at the rock it's nothing
in haha as a oh come on I see something
up there damn it I thought I had jumped
in G damn it oh well I guess I can't go
hello I hear you I see you who are you
chop it oh it's an empty container I was
hoping it would have gas in it but
that's something an empty jerrican is
that what those are called jerry cans uh
price i'm british thing come on I see
something up there I see something up
there there's got to be something else
here it's awfully nice that there was
like that audio clue for that can I
would have totally overlooked that um
what's that some moss nothing and look
at all these insignificant things I'm
like hey what's this hey what's that
and maybe this adventure game isn't as
complicated as I think it is I've only
got two items or once again the more
likely choice I am very stupid and then
missing some pretty obvious stuff
flowers dirt whoa oh it's a pile of dirt
ha ha it's a pile of dirt
hit with the ax ha ha oh come on it's a
pile of dirt what am I gonna do with a
pile of dirt why is there a pile of dirt
here did I run a note about the pile of
dirt
no I didn't heard a woman scream square
the village Oh
uh-huh uh-huh I need to go in that yeah
that won't sell it but there's a pile of
dirt here I would have totally missed
that
okay whatever all right whatever maybe
there was like a shovel in the wine
cellar that I could get there's got to
be a shovel if I have an axe most likely
there's a shovel that I can use right
maybe there was another tool at the
little wood chopping area that they had
over there hey let me just make sure
that I haven't missed anything else it's
really dark so it's highly probable that
I'm missing stuff huh Kip I found a pile
of dirt I can't believe I'm so excited
that I found a pile of dirt but that
would have been easily overlooked hmm I
found a pile of dirt I found a pilot oh
I bet I bet the lady was like looking
near the river there should be a pile of
dirt that you can find something all
right then
I thought I was special I don't see a
shovel I don't see anything I know I do
not see nothing is there anything up
there no this is an invisible wall again
with the invisible walls all right all
right way I think I got all the items
down here I can now go back into the
village and try to find something
something I'm not exactly sure what
hopefully the big blue barrel the big
blue barrel about add gas in it ah yes
yes I'll chop it open with my axe and
that I will do uh something else there's
got to be something I can chop with my
axe
very important chop it anything hello
can i chop you I will chop the hell out
of your ha ha actually worse
oh no wait I just used it looks like
there's some gas left in it your ass I'm
awake I'm so smart ha ha ha oh come on I
need something to help you extract the
gas with just lift the thing over your
head and dump it in tilt it over if
you're whippy oh come on
I'm right here what's in that bag
looking thing there's something that bag
that I can use there seems no this bag
not the vet spot oh come on
I'm guard took chop you open a cha I
don't need to smash it I think I do
oh how come on I was so close okay
there's got to be something in town that
I need to chop open because I got this
axe there must be a reason to use it
like I can get some tube maybe maybe
that lady knows what to do she'll
probably give me a clue or something I
have no idea oh I can chop one of these
doors down break the locks
let me just hang on I bet one this won't
do
you won't do what I want you to do huh
come on I have a giant axe I really am a
psychopath in this game RNA it's not
locked it's just a little bolt jump over
it really
this is stopping you all right whatever
ha ha chop over in the well Bloo no no
no I can't even interact with you but
the gas was in the thing anyway so this
isn't important to me ok maybe there was
a shovel down somewhere in here hang on
hang on maybe if I use the axe from the
Jerry can use Jerry Ken on the ax nope I
I still can't say anything down here but
I'm hoping that there's like a shovel or
something to get in that pilot oh what's
that
this looks like a funnel this looks like
a funnel I got a photo can I use this
funnel is this a funnel it looks like a
funnel it really does it looks like a
funnel hang on I don't know how there's
gonna help me get it out of the
container but I got some I got some I
got some I'm doing mark look at me
hobo's only flood oh no no it didn't
work all right let me put this back here
in case I need I'll probably need the
funnel to put the dump the jerk in into
the generator that's probably what I'll
need to do so let me just put things
back where they go it was it why is that
window open why is why is no one in this
town why am I asking so many dumb
questions whatever whatever
okay let me just make a quick look
before I cut this episode I want to make
sure that I'm not overlooking anything I
need to keep axing down doors
scuse me I need to ask you a question I
need to ask you a question the blood I
should chop the blood
I don't think any of these are gonna
work there's a whole big store here why
can't I go into any of these was that
thing what are these things what are
these things
sir madam madam blood
this won't do I can't use this here
maybe I can scoop it up with the Gerry
Khan maybe I can touch it it looks like
blood it tastes like blood - smells like
blood all right no all right I'm at a
loss
I think hello madam no need to chat now
come on maybe I could get something from
my car I could chop something off of my
car like a like a fuel line or something
that's the only thing that I know of cuz
I haven't seen anything here let me just
run up to the car real quick just to
cross that like off my list and if if
there's nothing there then then I've
just have to defer to you guys to try to
tell me what to do because apparently
I'm terribly stupid I'm terribly stupid
hmm and it is kind of creepy that
nothing has happened so far but that's
actually part of a good thing because
the way amnesia did it in the beginning
of amnesia you didn't even see a monster
until like you were like 30 minutes into
the game and that's a great way to do
because it allows room to build on I
mean amnesia was a long game so it needs
a lot of pacing and I don't know how
long this game is but it's probably got
a couple hours with the content in and I
would imagine if nothing else it's at
least like more than five six parts okay
I have an axe
I haven't axe and I am going to chop
into this chop it the rock destroyed the
car there was no point in coming back
here anyone was there I can't get
anything from this ah get gas from my
car this would make the most sense get
gas from the car well why couldn't you
why wouldn't you there was no point in
coming back up here was there I'm gonna
I'm not walking around like an idiot
with a gas can friend me okay so I I'm
all out of time and I'm all out of
brainpower to solve this puzzle so you
guys need to step in and assist for the
assist
I'll give you let's play
it's your new system let's play points
for every time you help out you get one
let's play point you can turn them in
for smiles and hugs because I don't have
any gift to give away by anyway so
that's all the time I got for this time
let me know what you think I need to do
in the next part in the comments below
let me know what you think of this game
try for yourself link is in the
description so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
Oh
bad
then someday